[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis vient la parole d'acs une simili
seulement lundi puis cette semaine en
prévision du camp froid qui arrive on va
commencer à penser au temps des fêtes et
surtout dans le temps de revivre ça va
être un peu spécial cette année les
jeudis c'est de me faire un cadeau à
moi-même et de répondre à une question
qui venait du public de julie qui est
enseignante au cégep qui me demandais
comment ça se fait autant d'auteurs
qu'ils sont et nous au québec pourquoi
est ce cas autant de présences de
d'auteur et cuba et nous et si c'est une
question que je vais vous répondre parce
que est quand même beaucoup d'auteurs
autochtones au canada
cependant comme on n'a pas choisi un
endroit où on serait quand le
colonisateur est arrivé est bien une
section du canada il y avait le québec
qui a une francophonie très active et
dans cette cette province c'est bien
pour tous les groupes autochtones ont le
français comme langue seconde
après leur langue autochtone d'origine
alors et beaucoup de personnes qui sont
anglophones je pensais qu'il lui a passé
aussi ou
mme horrocks il ne nous résignerons
tombe dans une poche territoriales qui
fait que grande partie de la population
quand même une des nations les plus
présentes sur les méthodes québec est
tombé dans une pochette de francophonie
donc nous parlons français soit comme
première langue ou soit comme langue
seconde
après l'hymne aux moines et ce qui fait
que beaucoup de gens vont connaître
énormément d'auteur nous d'auteur qui
sont toutes nations si je dois y est les
abénakis et les eti québec et un cordeau
mais on est quand même plus nombreux
donc les chances pour pouvoir avoir des
personnes qui sont des écrivains à
travers un grand groupe de la population
augmente
on a des auteurs au total de fonds qui
sont traduits et qui sont publiées au
québec
mais cette rencontre est difficile d'en
avoir d'ailleurs on me demande souvent
est ce que tu connais des auteurs
jeunesse que trenet des auteurs féminins
et c'est très difficile d'avoir une
version d'un auteur qui serait traduit
en français donc beaucoup de nous sont
représentés mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
s'arrêter uniquement à nos autres parce
que c'est sûr que j'ai prêché pour ma
nation les auteurs y nous sont quand
même très très bon mais il yad'autres
longtemps qu'il y en avait partout pas
seulement que d'aller aux états unis et
à travers le monde sont des groupes
autochtones et justement à partir du 25
novembre et bien c'est le salon du livre
qui veulent débuter salon du livre des
premières nations qui va voir sa
neuvième édition une édition virtuelle
donc juste avant le temps des fêtes
qu'on cherche des idées cadeaux quand on
veut justement créer une ambiance de
réconciliation combattre le racisme
systémique et bien s'informer sur la
culture des uns et des autres c'est ma
manière et à travers le salon de vie
vous avez trouvé des petites perles que
vous trouverez peut-être pas
nécessairement dans tous les grands
magasins de donc fait tout plaisir
chercher le salon du livre autochtone et
en plus c'est un salon du livre qui
habituellement au lieu à wendake
mais là on va le trouver en ligne il va
y avoir beaucoup de balades au heiva
beaucoup de webinaires qui vont se faire
et ça va quand même assez intéressant
à découvrir alors n'hésitez pas à
découvrir les auteurs qu'ils soient innu
ou de notre nation aller chercher au
salon du livre des petites perles rares
devrait offrir à noël et ce n'est pas
non plus à nous envoyer des questions
parce que je surprends contente de
répondre et surtout quand c'est des
questions qui ouvre la discussion vers
des choses beaucoup plus pointu et des
explications aussi qui nous font
réapparaître justement dans les archives
bm